Paul is starting us off this hour in
Illinois hi Paul welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show okay Dave love you let me
fill all I'm an effect contractor and I
just started offering nominee I'm sorry
Europe what contractor HVAC okay okay
yep and I've recently started offering
financing on my equipment and if you
know the price is built into the
financing cost is built into the
equipment how do i morally offer
financing while following the Dave
Ramsey plan well I mean there's two or
three levels of this one is obviously I
am Dave Ramsey and so if I offered
financing it would be as hypocritical as
anything on the planet so we don't take
credit cards we'll take your debit card
and we obviously don't know if we're
financing that would be completely wrong
if someone is following our stuff I
guess it would depend on how viciously
angry you are about debt if you just go
hey that's a bad idea I like this plan I
got out of debt and then your company
offers it let's say you owned a
restaurant would you take credit cards
probably you know that would be a fairly
normal normal thing to do if you're not
me if there was a Dave Ramsey restaurant
if I took credit cards I'd be on the
front page of the newspaper right so
because there might be trolling for days
but in your case you're not you know
you're not held to that standard of
hypocrisy so to speak the thing I would
tell you is this that you want to be
careful of just as a matter of business
ethics a good rule of thumb in business
is and for that matter in life is just
don't don't do things with other people
that you wouldn't want done to you treat
other people like you won't be treated
and so if this is 38% financing on your
stuff I think you should stop doing it
that's immoral but if it's a reasonable
thing it's zero interest for a period of
time and then if they don't pay it off
there's a rate that's reasonable or
something and you choose to do that and
build it in I'm not gonna be mad at you
I would tell people if they
asked me not to do it me but I don't
think you are doing something around my
cousin owns a chevy dealership he's not
an immoral guy financing cars for people
buying a Chevy from him right sure
but but and he said he's a debt averse
guy by the way he doesn't he doesn't
care for it did any debt personally but
obviously they sell cars and a lot of
people put payments on cars again not
what I recommend but I'm not mad at
every Chevy dealer in America you know
it's just not the case like so I'm not
mad at an HVAC dealer that offers a
stuff if you were advertising locally on
the local radio station I couldn't
endorse the financing plan but I could
endorse your company for being a good
heat and air company but in your case
what you want to do is you just say gosh
I'm gonna treat other people like I
would want to be treated and if you're
real hardcore you would say no financing
then if you're medium you would just say
well this is a fair price on this
financing it's not a ripoff but if it's
a ripoff thing you should just not
engage in it right okay no that
definitely makes a lot of sense and you
know only I don't want to with anybody
else and that's the old nature of my
business yeah you know one of the early
you know and what I would do - I mean
you know again if you were sitting there
with some young couple and you're
talking to them and you realize they're
up a creek they're so deeply in debt
they can't breathe and they're a buying
their one - had 42 add-ons to your
install you know a filter for this an
electron electrical filter or whatever
like electrostatic filter or all other
stuff and you know humidifiers and
they're just going bananas with the
install all because it's financing if
that was your kids you would tell them
not to do that and finance all that and
so tell that young couple that you know
don't do that guys well here's another
way you can do this until you get your
finances squared around and then you
call me back and I'll come over and
we'll do the rest of the work and I'll
show you how I'll do the work in such a
way we can do the add-ons later or that
kind of a thing again just if it was
your kids sitting there your 28 year old
sitting there would you want them to do
would you want someone to do them and
you know we've all had that where we've
had a friend or relative and
somebody came in and fleeced them and
they just just well it's their
responsibility yeah it is their
responsibility it's my responsibility to
to be moral about it